hi everyone
welcome to this tutorial on microsoft
excel
so we will learn about functions and
formulas we will learn about conditional
formatting
data validation pivot chart and pivot
table
now let's look at a scenario here so
one day in a startup
one professional speaks that their
business is growing
and they would need an efficient way to
work with
the data they would have to find a way
to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another colleague responds
well we can make use of microsoft excel
to do this job the question is
will excel be able to cater to their
business needs
now the colleague responds well
we can make use of excel in several ways
and
it also is a cost efficient option
now in that case the colleague who posed
the question
says let's go ahead with excellent let's
train our employees
in excel and
the suggestion is welcomed which would
make the job
easier for them and they would basically
decide on using excel so they decide on
taking a training right away
and basically starting to learn excel
now before we move to excel
one of the question is why should we use
excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so excel proves to
be a great platform to perform various
mathematical calculation
on large data sets which is one of the
biggest requirements
of various organizations these days
various features in excel like
searching sorting filtering makes it
easier for you to play with the data
and excel also allows you to beautify
your data and present
it in the form of charts tables and data
bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting
and analysis can be performed with the
help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal
planning worksheets excel also provides
good security for your data
excel files have the feature of password
protection
this way your information can be safe
now when we talk about what is excel and
how
it can be used so excel or
you might have heard a spreadsheet can
be basically used for
a lot of different tasks than just
storing the information
in so called tabular format
now microsoft excel is an application
that is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data
it is in the form of a spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas
used in excel and before we do that we
can also
quickly take a small tour to understand
how to work with excel now to do that
what we can do
is we can type in in our search
say for example excel and just select
your
excel app which is installed and here
you see you have a lot of options which
says
take a tour drop down list get started
with formulas
make your pivot table going forward with
pie charts
and much more so we can click on this
one which says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says
welcome to excel and if
you have always wanted to be better at
excel
you have this which can help you so
let's click on create
and that takes us to the store window
now that says
instructions for screen readers which
basically
talks about 10 different steps in which
we can learn
excel and using the spreadsheet app
so there are more than 11 sheets
which we see here at the bottom end and
each one gives us a simple
example which we can work on so for
example
if i click on add now that takes me to
this page which says
how do we add numbers now you might be
provided data which we can
upload by loading a file from our
machine or getting data from a web
source or even connecting to a database
so there are various options which we
will see
in some time so here we have an option
which is called data you can click on
this one
and this basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some
you can always click on from other
sources and you can get your data from
sql server
from analysis services from odata data
feed
you can get in from xml from data
connection wizard
or also from microsoft query you can be
running in different queries here which
shows up in the option which says new
query
there are connections which you can use
and that basically will display all the
connections
for this particular workbook which we
did not have as of now but we can create
them
but let's look at simple examples now
you can follow these instructions here
which says basically adding up the
numbers
and that could be easily done by just
placing your cursor here
and what you could do is either you can
type in the formula
that is from which row to which row
you would want to add the data so for
example i could just do
a sum here and that shows up all the
different functions which are available
then we can open up a parenthesis and we
can say
i would be interested in totaling the
amount
from column d and
i would select for example d4
so i could be doing this and then i
could say d4
onwards till d7 so that's the
data which i'm interested in you can
close your parenthesis and hit
enter and that gives you the total there
is also a shortcut for this
which you can always do is we can first
delete this
and you can just place your cursor here
and just use your alt and
equals that automatically selects the
numericals
which we can anytime expand
or basically collapse so i will
basically select this which says this
function needs two numbers
which is number one and number two and
then you can hit on enter
and that gives you the total so
similarly
we can be getting in the data here
by selecting all the fields so here it
also says that you
can use a shortcut now what we can also
do is we can add numbers
over 50 by selecting the
yellow cell here and then giving a
condition
such as so i can basically use something
like sum
if and then open a paranthesis
i can select i would be interested in
this row
and then i can even drag and drop
till here so that tells me d11 to d15
you can then put in a comma here and you
can give your condition
say for example we would say i would be
interested
in numbers only above 50
and we can select this close your quotes
and then just close your parenthesis
and that's your formula so you can do
this and that basically gives me the
total is hundred
now similarly we could do that for the
amount here
i could select this now there is also an
option i can click on home
and i can go for something like auto sum
so that's one more way
of doing it which anyway says sum
is alt plus equals so it automatically
adds up your values and i can try doing
a auto sum
that automatically selects my rows
and then i can get my total now as per
this
activity here it says try adding another
sum if formula
here but add amounts that are less than
100
and the result should be 160. so what we
can do
is we can basically select all the
numbers which are
lesser than 100 so the way we did
earlier here
there can be always a shortcut so you
can always
for example if you would want to avoid
typing in the formula you can always
copy it from here
and then just hit on enter
so you are back into this cell and then
i can basically go here and paste
the number and then as per the
requirement we
are required to select anything which is
lesser than
100 so what i could do is i could select
here
i could say let's say g and then i can
change this value to g15 and that's one
more way now we see
our selected rows have been changed
so i can hit on enter and i can check
what is the result so we would be
interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100
so i will have to also change this one
to
a lesser sign and that basically gives
me
the total which is 160
so that's how you can simply add numbers
you can use
autosum you can type in the formula you
can select the fields
or you can just place your cursor where
you would be looking for a sum
and then you can just do a alt equals
and that basically populates the
sum
now let's look at some easy options of
filling your cells or automatically
populating the values
in your cells within your excel sheet
now here we have an option with says 100
now we can click on this and that
basically says
it is making a sum of
c4 to d4 so if i click on this one
i can check that this is row number 4
which shows up here and i also know this
is column c i also have d so this
equals is basically giving me a sum of
c4 to d4
now what we can do is we can always
place our cursor here at the right
corner
and then we can just drag and drop and
this basically gives me a total
of all the numbers for all different
rows so this is one shortcut which we
can do
to get the total excel will
automatically give the totals which we
call as
filling down now what we can do
is in the same way if we would want to
get the totals here
we can first check what is this 200 and
this tells me it is
c 11 to c 14 so it is
totaling the rows from c11
so column c and 11th row till 14th row
and that's the sum now what i can also
do is
i can similarly like above we can
do a filling right which basically means
bringing your cursor here
and then just dragging and dropping it
all the way where you would need the
totals
and this basically gives me the total
there is one more quick way to check
if this is right so the easiest option
would be
to select this cell now what i can also
do is i can just
select all of these fields by just
highlighting and selecting all the
fields once it is selected
press on control r and that gives you
the total
now if we would be doing this top down
then i could select
all these rows for this particular
column and then i could do a control d
so that's your filling down and this one
was
filling right so this is an easier
option of doing a
fill when you would want to have the
formula
applied to every row as it occurs
in the first row or the last row
we could test this by for example
selecting these fields
i could delete them and i have here
which says 130
i could just place my cursor here and i
could drag it all the way up
and that should also do the same magic
which we were seeing from
top down so this is a simple way wherein
you can
fill up your cells and you can also
automatically
propagate or move your computation to
all the cells let's
look at the split option which basically
helps us
in splitting the data when we have some
kind of pattern
or when we have some kind of delimiters
in our data
in say one particular column and we
would want to derive the values out of
it
so we can always use the splitting
option
now the easiest option would be so for
example we have our email column which
has the email
ids and which we can clearly see has a
first
name dot last name now i see that there
is a last name smith filled up here
first name is
empty so what i can also do is i can
just type in
say nancy here now that's
the first name i can again start typing
the second name and as soon as you
do that you would see a faded list
of numbers and that's your clue to hit
enter and once you do that you would see
all the first names have been filled in
here if you would want to maintain the
case sensitiveness
you can just go ahead and delete these
and let's type in
as it occurs so let's say nancy as the
first name
go down to the next cell and just type
in andy
and there is your grade list so just hit
on
enter and that basically fills up your
first name
what we can also do is we can
just select this particular field and
either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now i can just do a undo by typing in
or clicking control z and that's
basically gone
what i can also do is i can select a
particular field
and then i can go into home option
and under home you should have an option
here which says
fill so you can select this and then you
can do a flash fill which is
what we are doing here so click on flash
fill
and that automatically fills up the
values so in this way you can work
within your spreadsheet and you can be
filling up the values where
a delimiter by default is understood and
we can split the data
now however sometimes you might have
some data which has a different kind of
delimiter
and there is again a smarter way of
splitting your data
so you can always scroll down here and
that says splitting a column based on
delimiters
so we have some values in the data
column and
these values in each row are separated
by
comma so select this
your data is already selected text to
columns delimited
comma is selected and now click on next
so it basically says what is the
destination let's select this one
and i can choose what would
you want to have so that shows me this
would be my data preview
now i can basically select this one
i can say finish and say okay
and now if you see our data has been
placed in
in the columns appropriately so this is
how you can split your data based on a
delimiter
and then organize your data in a better
way now there are some advanced options
which we can learn later but this
basically tells about
using a formula so this is something if
say
if we have some name in one cell and if
you would want to split it into first
name
your helper column your middle name
last name so that can also be done using
formulas
and this basically tells how would you
extract
characters from your left cell
and how would you place them in your
right cell so you can try this
activity which is a little more of
advanced option the benefit
is that you can always use this
wherein if you do some kind of
transformation
using your formulas if your original
data gets
updated then the split data will also
get
updated and that's the benefit of using
formulas
where you can place values from one cell
into multiple cells based on execution
of your details in the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your
columns into rows and that's where
transposing comes into picture
it might be useful when you have your
data
in your x and y axis so as i would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become
your rows so what we can do is the
simplest way is you can
select all your values
so here we basically have six columns
and i would say
two rows now i can select all of these
and then i can select an empty field
for example the one which is highlighted
here well you can always do a
control alt v that's a shortcut
what you can also do is once you have
selected all your fields
you can just copy them so just do a ctrl
c
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do
is you can do a special paste or paste
special so
under your home you have the paste
option and here you can go for paste
special
and once you do that you need to select
the transpose
option over here and click on ok and now
you will see that the columns and the
rows have been transposed
so your row name was item and that has
become the column heading
you had row name as amount and that has
become the column heading
and all your values have been transposed
in this particular format now there is
another way of doing that
and again that's using your formulas so
what you can do
is you can transpose with a formula also
and that basically works
when you have similar kind of data so
this has six columns
and basically two rows so you can
basically
do this so you can select this and
earlier
we were doing a copy but now what we
would want to do is we would want to
just look at the row numbers
which tells me it is c 33 c 34
and it starts with c and ends in with
your h column
so what we can do is we know that we
have six
columns and two rows so transposing that
would actually give me two columns and
six rows
so what we can do is we can select
two columns and six rows in our excel
sheet
i can then basically start typing in the
message or i can just go to the address
bar
and here i can say
transpose let's go for c33
h34 it basically selects my data
and now i can just do a
control shift and enter and now if you
see
all the values have been populated now
you can
just place your cursor in one of the
cells but if you see the address bar
the formula remains the same this is
because this is an
array formula so we can read more about
an
array formula here it's basically
something which performs calculations
on more than one cell in an array and
in the example here the array is the
original data that is c33
to h34 so your transpose is just
changing
the horizontal orientation to the
vertical
orientation so this is a very simple way
in which you can
basically use the excel's capability to
transpose your data
and convert your rows into columns and
columns
into rows apart from working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data
sorting the data or basically splitting
your data
transposing your data one of the other
requirements is
sorting and filtering your data now that
can be very handy when you're working on
huge data
and you would want to sort it in a
particular order say ascending or
descending or might be based on a
particular
field or if that field was or if the
cell was highlighted with a particular
color
sorting the data so let's look at how
excel can be used for
sorting and filtering examples are
pretty simple here
so let's check that so if we're going to
sort and filter and say this is the data
i
have say for example i would want to
sort the values in the department column
alphabetically so what i can do is i can
select
department column and i'm already in the
home
tab i can straight away go here which
says sort and filter
i can then say sort a to z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department column
and once once i do this you would see
the data has been sorted
but it's not just this data we can just
do a control
z and check what are the values we have
so here we have meat
which is beef and ninety thousand
hundred ten 000
the values then you have bakery which
should ideally be the first
row if we sort it in alphabetical order
which goes with bakery as deserts
you have the values so we can check this
again so select department
and then just with sort and filter and
let's say sort a to z
and if you see the data has changed but
it's not just in
changing your first column but then it
has taken care
of all the data however the data has
been
sorted based on the department column so
you have bakery
which aligns with deserts which has the
values and now we have
all the data which has been filtered now
what we can also do
is we can sort december's amounts from
largest to smallest so what we can do is
we can basically click any cell in the
december column let's say 20
000 and then what i can do is i can go
into sort
filter and then i can say sort largest
to smallest so if you see bakery breads
is the row which has the smallest data
or might be you have
delhi sandwiches so that one looks also
smaller so let's do
a larger to smallest and if i do this
you would see the values have been
shifted now
so it is no more based on the department
column
because now the data is being sorted
based on the values
in the december column and you see
bakery
which was alphabetically the first one
has become
second last so either you can sort the
data based on a department column
which goes based on the values these are
all string values or words
so it sorts alphabetically if you have
numbers might be you can give some
values and you can
sort the data you could anytime
do a custom sort and you could basically
select if you would want to select the
data so i could do a custom
sort and then i could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting
what is the sorting needs to be done is
it cell values
is its cell color font color conditional
formatting
and then you can also choose the order
so that's one more way to do that
now if you scroll down that also shows
how you can
sort by date or a color so for example
if you would want to sort
based on the expense date so there are
different options
so what i can do is i can select this
date field i can just do a right click i
can go into sort
and then i can choose i would want to
sort
oldest to newest so since i selected the
date field
it basically has sorted all the data
and it has taken the expense date into
consideration
now there are these filters which you
see on the row headings
we could have also used those so i could
have selected this
and that basically says or mentions
which
are the dates i would be interested in
looking at i also have sort by color
here
i can do a sort oldest to newest or
newest to oldest so i could
also use these filters which have been
applied here
now we have the data which is in color
so if i would want to
basically select the color columns
or color cells i could select this i can
basically do a right click here and when
i go into sort
i could choose put selected color or
cell color on the top and that basically
will make sure that my data is sorted
and it has also sorted that in a
descending order
so in this way you can sort or basically
filter your data what we can also do is
we can add filters
so sometimes we can go for formulas
which we would want to use
what we can also do is we can
basically select the filter which has
been applied here
now how does the filter come in there so
if i would select
a particular row i could select a
particular row
and then i could decide if i would want
to just add a filter to this one
and that's how the filter has come in so
we have the filter
what we can do is we can basically click
on this drop down
and then you have something like number
filters
so we can always go here we can
basically choose one of these
so we can basically choose above average
so i could select this and then
basically it shows me the values
we could also delete the filter by
clicking on this one
and we could say well i'm not interested
in this filter anymore
so i could clear the filter and that
shows me all the values
or i could say that
let's click on some other field for
example
food i can go in here i can go into
number filters
and then i could say well i'm interested
in
values which are below average above
average might be greater than
and then i can choose what is the value
so for example if we say i'm interested
in food which is
greater than 25 dollars i could give a
value here
i could say okay and now i have applied
the filter
similarly you can select this and then
you can just clear your filter
and your data is back so remember no
data is
lost it is just hidden
or basically based on the filter not
shown
so that's good enough for us and in this
way you can
sort and filter the data so for more
details obviously in all the sheets you
have the links which point to more
information on the web
and you can always refer to these so
this is simple
way in which you can sort and filter any
amount of data
which has been stored within your excel
within a particular
sheet now that we have learned about add
fill split transpose sorting and
filtering
it will also be good to learn how to
work with tables
or basically converting your data into a
tabular format
and then doing some easy computations
so click on this tables option here now
here we see there is some data
which is in five columns and
n number of rows so i can basically
select
this data and then what i can do is i
can insert
choose the table option and then it says
my table as headers and we'll be okay
with that
i'll say okay and now if you see this is
the table created
it basically has different filters which
we have learnt earlier how to use
and this is basically my table which is
a collection of cells which has some
special features
so we can easily add rows to this table
we can add columns to this table and we
can even do some calculations
so for example here i can click on this
one
i can basically enter some field
and then i can hit on enter and we see
that this row has been inserted
wherein we can easily fill in values for
example i would say
chocolates i could give some value here
size 25 000 might be 35
000 and then basically i can given
some values here now what you can also
do
is you can continue adding rows in this
way
and say for example you would want more
columns
so you can select this option here
in the top bottom right corner you can
just
drag it towards the right and that
basically has
automatically created columns for my
next
month wherein i can feed in the data
so this is a simpler way wherein you can
keep
adding more rows and columns to your
data if that has been converted in a
tabular format
now let me just do a ctrl z that
basically deletes the columns
again control z deletes the last row
which we added
and i can stop here or i can even remove
my values by doing multiple control
z and removing my rows so this is how
i converted my data into a table
and then i can easily work on this what
i can also do is
i can do some calculations so what we
can do
we have a table here we have a total
field
and what we can do is we can just select
one
cell here now as we have learned earlier
we can do a
alt and then equals and that basically
says
what is this doing so it says it is
calculating the sum
of the last three months and if that's
what you would want to do just hit on
enter and it has automatically
calculated
the totals for all your rows
for these three columns so the sum
formula
is getting filled up now i can select
any particular cell
and i can look in my address bar so it
has already given me the formula
where it has started calculating the
sum from the october column till
the december column and has given me the
calculated values of the columns
what we can also do is we can get total
rows
in the table now that's a simpler option
so what we can do is we can select any
cell
in this particular table and then
we see that there is a table tools
design option showing up here
now i can select this and then it says
well let's get a total row so let's
select this
and it automatically populates the total
here
and if you would want the average then
we could select this
and from the drop down i can select what
i'm interested in
so for example i would want the average
values are not the total
i could just select this and that gives
me the average
of these values so we can always do
simpler computations here by converting
our data
into table format let's learn about one
more efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs
so let's see how drop downs work here
now say for example you have this data
which
has the values in the food column and
department is empty
and say for example you would want to
enter the values in department however
you would want to select
the department should either have
produce or meat
and bakery and these are the only three
options which
should be available for any user to fill
in the values
how do we do that so we can basically
create a table by pressing ctrl d
so what i can do is under my department
here i can select one of the cells and
then i can do a control t
that basically converts this into a
table i can say ok
and my table is created now what i can
do is
once this part is done
we can select all the blank fields here
where we would want this drop down to be
applicable
now under your data tab you can go in
and select data validation and this has
an option called data validation
click on this which basically says allow
any value so here i will select i would
want to give a list of values
and then i can type in my values here
which i can say produce
say for example meat and then say
bakery now these are the values so we
can click on ok
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to apples
which will only show us the values which
we can
feed in under the department column so i
can go into
every cell and then i can basically
choose
what is the department which handles
this
and then basically i can select one of
these from the
drop down so this is an easier option
of creating your drop down and then
feeding in the values
from the set of values which you have
defined here
on the right so this is a simple example
of using your drop downs
working with your tables working with
your sort and filter
transpose split filling up your data
adding in some data here and similarly
you can use excel for
more than one use case using its
inbuilt features to easily work with
your data let's see how we can import
data or bring in data into our excel
from your local machine or
from an external web source so
what we can do is we can open up a blank
excel sheet
and say for example you have been
provided
a text file or a csv file and you would
want to import that data into your excel
sheet
that can be easily done so right now
i've opened an
excel sheet now i can click on data and
here i have an option which says
existing connections from other data
sources
so or you can click on connections if
you have already created some
so we can click on from other sources
so this is one option where you can
connect to your different data sources
and you can get the data from
one of these what we can also do is i
can click on connections
now it says there is none i can click on
add
it says well show the connections where
connection
files on network connection files on
this computer
so i can say let's get some files from
this computer
now if that does not show up something
so say browse for more
and that basically shows you different
options so let's
basically select a folder where i have
some data sets i'll click in here
and this is basically a folder where i
have some data sets
now let me select this particular file
and i know it is a csv
file so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have
gone and looked into the properties of
the file and it says it is a dot csv
file which is what we are interested in
so i'll take this file
i'll say open now this basically shows
me
the text import wizard option which says
is the file delimited
i'll say yes click on next so i will
select
comma as my delimiter i can say text
qualifier is
none now this is my data
so my data preview is already showing me
the data
is what is the data in the csv file
you can click on next and then you have
an option which says data format
is general you can go for date format
you can go for advanced options
so i'll just say finish and basically
now this has been created here
so we basically have this and now i can
click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections
it shows me the data which we have here
the connection which we have created say
open and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data
into existing worksheet you can also say
add this to a data model
if you are doing some data modeling so
click on ok
and now this data is automatically
inserted in my excel file i can
basically
save it into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get
some other data from web so what i can
do
is i can go into my github and let's say
i would be interested in this csv file
so i can select this and this is my
github path a path on web
so i can click on draw and that
basically gives me
the raw path where this particular file
is now you can select this
copy this particular path and here
you can come back to your excel sheet we
would be interested in getting the data
from
web might be from a text file where we
will have to specify the delimiters
or let's go to web and here i can given
the web
path from where i would be interested in
getting the file
let's give the github path which is
publicly available
and then click on import now once you
click on import
it tells me there are two fields data
and value
these are within double quotes
separated by comma so first let's click
on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from web
and put in here it says existing
worksheet so we had already created a
new worksheet
so let's click on ok and now you have
the data coming in
but then this basically shows me in one
particular field so what we can also do
is we can just do a control
a that selects all my columns here
and that's my data so we can then
basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next
we can select comma and let the text
qualifier be
quotes it shows me data preview
click on next so you have the general
format
it shows the destination that's the
column
click on finish and now your data has
been split
and you have the data which you have
imported from web so this is
the data which is coming in from web
this is the data which came in from my
local machine
and similarly we can even create
connection with an existing database
so i can basically click on connections
if i would want to do that so i have an
option called connection here
and it says where the selected
connections are used
i can basically click on add i can
basically
choose if i would want to get the files
from network
or from computer like we did earlier i
can click on browse for
more which should show me
different other options to create
connections say you would want to create
a new sql
server connection you can connect to a
new data source coming in from different
place
you could basically choose what kind of
connection you would you want
so these are all the different options
which we can go for and
we can basically connect to a database
for example
if i have some database and say for
example
access database i can see if there are
some files with that particular database
and i can import it so similarly
we can also click in here which says new
query
and that also gives you an option of
getting the data from your files from
all these folders
from databases so you can basically
click here and then you can import data
from a mysql database
provided that is set up on your local
machine
or on a particular server you can go
from cloud
you can get it from online services you
can get it from
other sources which says from web from
your hadoop file system
from active directory from a blank query
and you can even combine queries wherein
you can run
a power query editor you can get the
data from different sources
and then you can bring it into your
excel so in this way
you can get your data from different
sources
into your excel into your spreadsheet
and then you can continue working on
those data sets
we have already learned some basic
operations which you can do in excel and
let's
implement our knowledge by working on
this particular data which is
coming in from housing data set now here
if we see some fields we have agent
date listed area list price and this is
basically the data which has been
sorted in newest to oldest order of date
listed so how do we
arrive at this so what i can do is
i can just click on data listed and then
i can either go in here
i can select sort i can get into custom
sort and then i can choose the column
based on which i would want to sort the
data so i would look for the newest data
to the oldest data that means that would
be in a descending order of dates
or you could say the oldest date or the
earliest month will be
towards the lower side of your sheet so
here we can select date listed
now i can say let it sort based on cell
values
and the order what we have here so we
have newest to oldest so let's select
this
i can say okay and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that
seems to be the latest date and as we go
down we will see
an earlier month hour and
earlier month than that in this date
listed so we have sorted our data
into newest to oldest order and that's
based on your
date column so the result shows up here
now what we can also do is we can have
different questions which we would want
to answer
so for example i would want to sort the
data in ascending order of
area and descending order of agent name
how do we do that so let's look into
this so
this is here i already have the result
here
and how did i get this so i'm looking
for ascending order of area
in descending order of agent name so we
can
start with any particular column that
does not matter
so for example if i look into this excel
sheet
i have my agent name select this which
we want in a descending order
so we could either do a sort and then go
for
descending sort z to a we could also
use the filter option here on the top
right and we could do it
or i could just say sort z to a and then
it has arranged the data
based on the agent column being in
descending order now i can go into area
and then i can again do a sort and i
wanted my area column
to be used for sorting the data
ascending to descending
and that basically not only changes the
order of this particular column but for
my complete data so let's do that
and now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so we can see
how many values we have here
and the area values which we see and
this is how you get your
result so i'll just do a ctrl z
and again and i'm back to my
original data and this is the sorted
result which we are seeing
at similarly we can answer other
questions for example sort the data
according to the following order
of area that is we are saying
county central and then your county
so we can basically choose in which
particular way we would want to do it so
it is county
central and then again county so
if i look into my sheet 3 so here
i basically have my data which is having
some south county
then you have your central and then you
have your
north county so we would want to sort
the data to solve our problem which is
according to the following order so
first we go for
area then we go for south county central
and north county so what we can do
is we can basically have area field
selected
and i would want to sort this particular
data
so i have south county central
and north county so i can basically go
for custom sort
and then i can choose which is the value
or
column which i'm interested in let's go
for area
we will go for something like
cell values well you can also try to
explore conditional formatting icon
if this is what you would want to use or
we can basically go for just cell values
and here we can say if i would be
interested in
first getting my values for south county
so for example i can say custom list
and then i can basically given the new
list here
so i can say s dot
county and then i would want
central and then i would want north
county so let's select this
as it exists we can basically
say add and that's basically the order
which we want to say
okay and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want
our data so we can compare that with the
values which we see here
it starts with kelly you have in the
12th row something like
lang and that's what we are doing so we
can basically
arrange the data in a particular order
by choosing a custom list and then
sorting your
data so that's one more simpler task of
what we have done where we have sorted
the data
in the order where under our area column
we first wanted south county
then we wanted central data and then we
wanted
north county so this is how you can do
it
now let's look into one more problem so
it says find
all the houses in the central area
and we would want to basically apply a
regular filter
let's let's see how do we do that so we
can click on this
and here we have the data so the problem
statement is
we would want to find all the houses in
central
area now how do we do that we can do a
sorting but
we would want to use the filter which
you see here
is implemented so how do you do it so
you can select this
area and say for example i would want to
apply filter
i can just go in here and i can say
let's get a filter
on my first row and now i have
filters applied so we are interested in
looking into the central
area houses let's go in here it says
all these fields are selected that means
it shows everything
wherein your area has all these values
let's
unselect this and then i will only be
interested in the central
so let's say okay and then say okay
so now you see that the area
filter has been applied and we are
looking at the central column
so what we have done is we have applied
a symbol filter
and we are looking at our data at any
point of time if you do not
want the filter
then what i can do is i can select this
and i can say well i'm interested in all
the data
so i could do this or you can clear the
filters from
area and you get your data back so
that's in one way you can filter out
your data
so let's look at an example of sort and
filter
where we might have to filter the data
based on two columns
or multiple columns with different kind
of values where it could be and and
or condition now say for example this is
the data i
have and this is the question which we
need to answer
such as find the list of all houses in
the central region
with pool and south county without pool
now if it was a simple filter based on
one cell
i could have just selected my
header row i could have then
applied the filter
and once i have the filter i can look in
area where i have three
regions so i'm only interested in
central and south county so i can get
rid of north county and that's fine
but then we have two different
conditions here so we need
the data in central region to
have the value for pool being true
and for south county the value has to be
without pool
now how do we do that so what we can do
is we can first create a copy of
these headers here so let me do that
now the area has to be south
county so basically i can either
just select this and i can choose this
value
and then i can select this and then i
can choose
central so that's the criteria which i
have
and the pool value has to be so
central region should be with pool
so then this one basically has to be
true and this one
has to be basically false so south
county is without pool
so let's select one of the values here
and this is my criteria
now to get my result uh we can always
place your cursor here
and you can check this is m column and
eighth row okay so we would want the
result here so let's go ahead and now
click on data and then in filter you
have an option called
advanced and here what i can do
is i can say i would want to filter the
list
in the place but that's not what i would
want to do so i'll say copy to another
location and
here if you see the list range will tell
me
that this is the data so a1 to j126 so
a to j column selected and all the rows
criteria range is basically based on
what i have given here so that is
m from 1
to v which is 3
so i am selecting these columns and then
i am saying
all the way whatever criteria i have
given and copy
2 i am saying m8
to v8 so that basically will give me
my filtered result so you could
basically just say
and now i have my data which has been
filtered
and i have my area which is south county
that is without pool central with pool
again south county without pool and then
if you look at your central value that's
pool so this is an advanced filter which
we have applied
where simply we have filtered the data
based on two columns
and then we have our result so in this
way
you can have your customized filter
applied on two different columns and get
your data
which can be either replacing the
existing content
or in the same sheet in different set of
columns and rows
you can have your result let's look at
one more example of filtering
where you are trying to filter the data
based on a
and condition condition being met in two
different columns and then you would
want to
filter out the data for only specific
columns so the situation is the agents
with a house in north
county that should be county area having
two
and a single type family so we are
talking about
two bedrooms and we would
basically have a single type family and
here the criteria
is that we would want to only populate
these columns which is agent area
bedroom and type
now what you can do is as i explained
earlier
that you can get your result in the same
sheet in a different location
so here i have created these headers
which says
agent area bedrooms and type
now this is basically a copy of all the
columns what we have here
agent data listed area list price
bedrooms
bath square feet and so on so you can
basically create a copy of the headers
here
and this is where we will give our
advanced criteria to filter the data
so the conditions which need to be met
is we need to look at
north county so for example here in
area i can basically go ahead and select
one of the values north county
now the criteria is having two bedrooms
only
so let's say bedrooms and let's say the
value should be
two and then basically i am saying
a single type family so when you would
want
the single type family so here under
type i can give the criteria single type
so this is my and condition so we are
saying north county area
having two bedrooms and the type is
single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if i select this
this one tells me that this is m
one row onwards till v
two so this is what we have and we would
want to filter based on this
so let's go ahead and then go for data
filter advanced and here in advanced
it says filter the list in place now
that's not what we would want to do so
i'll say copy to another location
this basically selects the list range so
which is telling me
a1 to j126
so that's the columns and rows selected
criteria range is based on m 1 v 2
which we have given here and copy 2
i would say for example from m 7
to p 7 now this is the area where i
would
this is the place where i want the
result let's say okay
and now i get my data which is
based on the question which has been
asked that
you would want the agents with a house
in north county area
having two bedrooms and single type
family so in this way you can basically
do advanced filtering get your data
and get it stored in the sheet anywhere
at a different location well i could
have also done
filtering in place and that would have
replaced
the data which we have but that's not
what we want we would want the filtered
result
in a different place so this is how you
can do some
advanced filtering we can also use excel
to
filter out the data in one particular
column
which might be conditional or say
using some numerical filters now here
say for example the problem statement
is that you would want to display all
the houses whose list price is between
45 000 to 600 000
or say for example we would want to
filter out the data to something else
say for example
let's say i have i would want to filter
out the data between 300
000 and 400 000 so we can
basically update this
say for example i'm saying i'm
interested in 300
000 to
400 000 and that's the criteria to
filter out the data now there are two
different ways or there are two
easier ways to do it one is i would want
to
look at the list price so i can select
this
i can go ahead and do a filter here
and in the list price now this is where
we would want to do the filtering so
it's pretty easy
you can click on this one and then you
can go into number filters
and you can choose between now that's
one easier way of doing it
so i could basically select this i could
say
i'm looking for value which is greater
than or equal to
300 000 and then
is less than or equal to 400 000
so if i just do this i have applied my
filter
and i have my data which is filtered
based on my
criteria right so that's one easier way
of doing it
or let me do a control z
now let the filter be there which you
can anyways use
but what we can also do is as we have
seen earlier methods
so get a set or
get your column headers here
and then you are giving two columns here
now the only difference between my
this set of columns which i have 1 2 3 4
and then you have 7 and 10 columns and
if you see
here we have 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 right
so whenever you want a and condition you
will basically
add the columns where i can give add
condition if it is the same column
if it was a different column then it
would be
same number of columns but and
conditions will lie in the same line
and all condition would lie in a
different line
now here i can give this value so i am
looking for
listed price being between 300 000
so i am saying it should be greater than
or equal
to 300 000
and then i can say less than or equal to
400 000 now that's my criteria
and then i need my result here which is
in
m7 so what i can do is
once i have given my criteria which i'll
be using
to filter i can get into data i can get
into
advanced and then i can say copy to
another location
so it is selecting my a1 to j126
criteria range is based on m1 to
w 2 and then i would want my result
from this particular column so let's say
okay
and now you have your data filtered out
in a different location in the sheet
which has been filtered based on your
and condition
so you can filter out the data in this
way or
you could just apply a filter on a
column and give the
conditions now let's solve one more
interesting problem
and here we would want to use excel
where we would have an
and and and or condition so say for
example this is the data given to you
and the question is that you would want
to find all the houses in
north county again that's a spelling
mistake but then the
north county area with a list price
greater than 300
000 and having three or four bedrooms so
the bedroom
has conditional so it has or three and
four
and then basically you have list price
which is greater than 300 000. now i
could have
obviously selected the columns
and then basically gone for a
filter so i can just do a filtering here
and then i'm looking for list price
being greater than 300
000 so which we can always give a number
filter
and i can say greater than and then
i can say greater than or equal
so i can say greater than and then i can
give three thousand thirty three hundred
thousand
and that's basically the filter which we
would want
and here i would want to select the
bedrooms
which should be just either three or
four so if for example here i go in here
and i unselect this and then i say three
and four
right so i am getting my data which is
greater than 300 000
and it should have the bettering values
which will be
either three or four selected now that's
one way of doing it
let's do a ctrl z and get it back
to as we were or you can even just say
clear
filter so you get your data back as it
was
so what we can do is we can here
give the criteria so for example i
have my list price now this is what
i would want as a condition so let's say
greater than three hundred thousand
three hundred thousand and bedrooms
should be
three and then i can say greater
than three hundred thousand
and then i can say four so this one
basically
gives me a situation where your list
price has to be greater than 300
000 and bedroom should be either three
or four so we have given our filtering
criteria
now to get the result what we can do is
we can go into data
we can go into advanced and we can say
copy to another location
so our list range is selected which is
columns a to j row number 1 to 126
your criteria range is given in m1 to v3
where we have specified and we are
saying the result would be in
m7 to v7 so if i do this
now i have got the same data which we
were seeing earlier
and here the bedroom values are 3 or
four
and basically the list price is greater
than three hundred
thousand so this is a simpler way in
which you can
create your filters and all this
advanced filtering what we are seeing
it will be saved with your sheet you can
always go back
and change this value or you could do
filtering where one person has to look
into the filter to see
what values have been selected
now that we have looked into some
operations which we can perform in excel
using
filter or sorting the data creating your
tables let's also
quickly look at functions and formulas
which can be used
for doing some easy calculations or
computations
now excel can be used in different kind
of data analysis
so for example you have different
inbuilt functions which can be used
and we can always check for a particular
function
so for example if i had if i wanted to
look at a particular function
i could just type in here
something for example is and then it
shows me
all the possible functions and you can
always have a look at the detail of the
function for example you have
is even which will return true if the
number is
even if we would say is logical
so i could search for is logical
and that tells me whether a value is
logical value true or false and returns
your value true and false
now we can obviously say
subtotal so you can search for any of
these useful functions and that tells me
what this function can be used for so
returns a subtotal in a list
or a database you have many other
such functions such as integer sum
average
you may be interested in working on
truncating
some data getting the absolute value
getting the square root
basically getting a count or getting a
max value
you can look for any particular
functions within your excel
sheet now you also have other functions
such as
now or time for example let's look at
now function so i can search for
now and here it is so this is
returns the current date and time
formatted as
a date and time so this is the function
which we would want to use
and if i just give the function
it tells me what is the current time
let's first look at the description of
time here
so say for example i would want time it
says converts
hours minutes and seconds given as
numbers
to an excel serial number formatted with
the time format
so for example if i would say 2
hours and then 30 minutes
and 30 seconds and if i do this
it has basically converted this into
your time format
so you can always use different inbuilt
functions
for your work if getting your learning
started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now we will also look at some advanced
functions like sum f
or sum ifs you have count f and count
ifs and you can be working on various
functionalities
of x l 2 easily help you in doing some
calculations
computations working with your data
working with your
different cell values so let's look at
some example of using functions like sum
or sum if so for that
let's go to this sheet and here we have
some data
now i have already applied a filter
which can allow me to filter out the
data
so it says find the total units that
were sold
in the east region now we know that
in region we have east
and i have multiple regions
i could basically be saying
unselect all and select only east
and say okay and that basically gives me
the units which were sold and if i
placed my cursor
here and then if i did a auto sum
so it would basically give me the
function which is being used so
something like subtotal
and it is basically working on
your rows which is e2 to e44
and here we can just do this so that
gives me
the total but this is this is fine
you could do that but it would be good
if we know how do we
use a function like sum if to do that
so here i'm seeing this is the subtotal
where i'm looking at the values and
basically what i have done is i have
filtered out the region
and then basically i am getting a count
but this does not give me clearly how
a sum was calculated from all the values
which were listed
what we can also do is let's do a ctrl z
and let's get it back
so now we have our data and we would
want to get the
total units that were sold in the east
region so what i can do is
i can start typing in my formula and
for that i'll use an inbuilt function so
for example i would be interested in
going for sumif
now it says sumif adds the cells
specified by a given condition
or criteria when you talk about some ifs
this
is when you could give set of conditions
or multiple criterias so let's look at
some if
let's do this now obviously this gives
me an error because the
formula is not right so
we have to basically come in here and
let's start with
sum if now when i say sum
if it shows me there is a function with
sumif which we would want to use and
here once i open up the bracket
it tells me okay what is the range of
data
which you are interested in so i am
interested in
all the units that were sold in the east
region so we are interested in the
region
which is here so i can basically be
selecting this and this tells me
you are interested in the data here so
let's not take the header
value so let's say b2 and then we can
go all the way to the end so we can
basically select this way
that's the data we have select this and
hit enter so
now here it has selected b2 to b4
but we need to basically now give the
criteria
so the criteria is either a value
or you can point it to a cell which has
that particular value so as per our
problem statement
we are looking for the units which are
sold in east region so i can select the
value
east here and then my sum if
needs the range on which you want to
calculate a sum so
let's select this and now we are
interested in finding out the sum of
units
so that's basically this column e column
so i can basically type in instead of
selecting
so i can say e and i'm interested in e2
2 e 44 so that basically selects the
area
or all the values and now let's do this
so that basically gives me the sum is
691
right now this is the criteria where i
have pointed it to a cell
and whatever value that cell has well i
could have
done something like this so i could have
selected east
giving the value and then doing it it
still does the same thing and in this
way you have more clarity
that you are using sumif you are
filtering
the data so you have given the rows you
are
given the criteria and then you have
given the range
on which you would want to sum up the
values
now similarly if the question was what
was the total revenue generated from
binder now we would want to find out
what is the total revenue generated from
binders that means
my filtering criteria will be binder
and then i want to find out the total
revenue generated so we have the revenue
generated field
also here and we have we don't have any
region to be filtered we are just
looking for binder
so let's again start doing the same
thing
so we can go for some if we can open the
bracket now it needs the range so we are
interested in revenue generated
now that's the summation we want and we
would want to
get the range of data so here
we can basically select uh
d 2 2
d 44 so that's the
data selected now i would want to give
the filtering criteria so
let's say binder and then we need to
give the range on which the sum
needs to be calculated so that's my
revenue column
so that's g so i can say g
2 to g 44
and that basically selects the column
and then you get your sum
so it tells me what is the total revenue
generated
from binder now i could be doing this
for
other things also so say for example if
you would want to
filter out something else you could
basically just drag and drop here
and then i could come here and change
this to
say instead of binder i would be
interested in say pencil
if that's the criteria you're interested
in
remember to change this so that you take
all the values
and here we will change it
to select the relevant rows and then
this is the data i am getting so i know
that this is the revenue generated
from pencil this is the revenue
generated from
binder now this is a simple use case
where we are using some
if what if we would want to use
some ifs so some ifs
let's have a look at how we get to some
ifs
so some f says where you would want
to work on doing some calculation
but then you would want
multiple criterias to be met so let's
see how we get this
so here what i can do is
let's work on this problem statement
which says what is the total revenue
generated from
central region where
the item is a pencil so
that's something which i would want to
check now when we are answering this
question we can
also look at the order in which things
have been asked in the question
so it says what is the total revenue
generated
from central region so we need the total
revenue generated we know there is a
revenue column
we are interested in getting the total
revenue generated
we are saying the filtering criteria is
central region
and we say in that we would be
interested only in the item
if it is pencil how do i do it so i can
use sumifs where you can pass
in multiple criteria so let's start with
some ifs and when i start
with some ifs let's open up the bracket
so it says sum range
it says criteria range then it gives one
criteria
and you can give in any number of
criterias so for example we are
interested in total
revenue generated now that's my g column
so let's
follow in the same order so let's say g
2 so that's my first value and then
i know there are 44 rows here so i can
say g
44 and you can obviously check
if that has selected all the rows
now that's my total revenue generated
so i would want the total revenue
generated so am
saying setting this sum range
then i need to give the criteria range
so it says from central region so
central region
comes into column 2 that's b
so let's say b 2 to b 44
so that's my criteria range then
you have to give your criteria but
we need to filter out the region being
central
so let's select this now either i could
point
to a value in the cell or i can just
give the exact value here we can also
give
a wildcard or matching
pattern so that also works now this one
is fine
we are now also interested in finding
the
total revenue generated when the region
is central and the item is pencil how do
we do that
so for item we know the columns
the column is d2 so let's select d2
to d 44 so that basically selects
all the rows in the d column and we need
to give the
filtering criteria so let's do a comma
and then just given our value so let's
say
pencil and then let's close your bracket
and that basically gives you the result
so
we need to just follow the order of our
question which says
what is the total revenue generated so
we are looking at the revenue column we
are
selecting all the rows then it says
from the central region so we need to
select the region
column and give the filtering criteria
as central
or point to a cell which contains that
value
and then it says we would be interested
only in
item being pencil so then you select the
column
which has all the items and provide your
filtering criteria
that is pencil so that's your
easy calculation of using sum if which
we compare
with sum if here so sum if here was
just having your
criteria so basically you are selecting
your rows
giving your filtering criteria and then
your sum range
in some ifs we are giving multiple
condition now same thing can be done
here
it says how many units were sold by
sales representative
john's or jones where the cost of each
item was greater than four
so how many units were sold
by sales representative
so when we talk about how many units
that's your e
column so let's start with that
so let's say some ifs i would be
interested in e
column then let's give the range
so it says sum range so those are the
number of units on which we would want
to find
the sum then it says you need to give
the criteria range
so we say sales representative where the
name is
jones so sales representative is in
sales rep column c
so let's say c2 to c44
now then we need to give our filtering
criteria
so let's say jones is the sales
representative where we are interested
about whom we are interested in and then
we
the question says where the cost of each
item
so cost of each item is what we are
interested in
you have unit cost so that's what we are
interested in so that would be
f and then say f2 to f44
and then you need to give your cost
so it says where each item
is greater than
4 so let's select this
and let's do this
so this tells me three zero one
now similarly
let's answer our third question which
says how many units did
jones sell excluding pencil item
so we would want to find out what was
the total number of units
units that were sold
and that units or that
should not include the pencil item how
do we start doing this
so let's start with sum ifs
now we know that you start with some ifs
you need to give the sum
range so we are interested in the number
of units
so let's basically go in and select
our number of units which were sold so
that's your
column e so i can say e2
to e44 that's where i would want to
perform this
sum now i'm saying
how many units that were sold where
we are talking about sales rep being
jones so
let's see let's select the columns
c and then give
the range after that we need to give our
giving
filtering criteria which is jones and
then we
are interested in the items
but excluding pencil so
items is in column d so let's say d
to d 44 and then
we have to give our
criteria so we can say well that should
exclude
pencil so i can basically say
pencil and
let's close this and let's check
so that's my formula which says that
these are the number of units which the
sales representative whose name is jones
had
sold and that does not include
pencil as an item let's also look at an
example of using countif or count
ifs now both of these can be very useful
when you would want to calculate certain
values
so for example if i would want to work
on count if let's try solving
this problem now remember you can
answer these questions using filters and
that can be an
easier way but then sometimes you may
want to
get the formulas so that you can make
your spreadsheet and your calculation
more dynamic in nature
and that will basically depend on the
values in the
columns or rows so for example if i have
find the total number of times
gil has made a sale now if i look at my
data here
it tells me that for every sales
representative there is some value
in the sale and it says sales has
greater than three
so for example jones you have sales
greater than three
or you have jardine which is
sales greater than 3 and so on so what
we are interested
in is doing a quick count in finding out
the total number of times gil has made a
sale how do we do that so we can use
this count if
function and if i go into count f it
says counts
the number of cells within a range that
meet the given condition
now what's our condition our condition
is
kill and we would want to find out how
many times the name
say gill appears or kill has made
a sale now i could just say count if
and then open up a bracket i need to
give a range
so let's say we are interested in
looking at
the range so let's say we will choose
sales rep so i can say c and then i can
say
c 2 to c 44
now that's my range
let's not give that in quotes
so you have to give a range so let's do
a count if
that selects the data and then we need
to give the
condition so for example let's here
give the name which is gil and then
close this so that basically tells me it
is five times
kill appears here we can check this so i
can go in here
i can add a filter
and then might be i would be interested
interested in looking at
only gill and that basically gives me
five right so we can always do that
and we can be using formulas like this
now
what about this question so which
basically says
which sales representative made a sale
more than three times
now we it might be looking a little
confusing when i
say for example let me clear out this
filter
now we have sales greater than three
and we would want to find out which
sales representative
made a sale more than three times
now i could basically check for every
sales representative here if they have
made a
sale more than three times and what i
can do is i can just
say equals i can start with count if
then i need my filtering criteria
so that's your range so first thing is
we will choose for example let's choose
c2 to see 44
and then we need to
give and criteria what is the criteria
we need basically a sales representative
so i can choose the value here
in c2 and then
i can close this and then i can say the
sale has to be greater than 3
and let's check so it tells me the
boolean value
that yes this guy has made
sales more than three times and what we
can do is we can just
drag and drop which basically gives me
the value for other
sales rep you can always check the value
is automatically changing to this
value in cell and for example let's go
in here so this is obviously
two so it says me false right and
you can basically get the values for all
your values
so that basically tells me which
sales representative has made a sale
more than
three times now like some ifs
we also have countifs where you can give
multiple criterias
so for example the question is how many
orders were placed from the
east region after this particular date
so we have a date criteria
we also have the region criteria and we
need to
basically get the count of number of
orders which were placed now i can
in this case use count
ifs and this basically says that
you can start within criteria so it says
how many orders were placed from
east region after particular date
so date is in my
first column so for example i could say
a start with 2 and
say for example let's go a 44
that should have selected all the rows
and then i need to once i've given the
criteria range i need to give the
criteria
so we are saying the date has to be
greater than 10th feb
so let's give it 2
10 2019
and then you need to say how many orders
were placed
so you need to give the criteria second
criteria range
so we are looking at the number of
orders
which were placed from the east
region so when i would want to look at
the region that's your column b
so i can basically say b2 to b
44 and here
i would basically give my criteria so
the criteria
is east
let's give that and once you have done
this
you would want to find out the total
number of orders so let's select this
and if i do this it tells me 13
now is that right so we are looking for
your date your region being
east and then getting the total number
of orders
so here i can just to account if
i'm saying 82 to a 44
wherein i have given the date criteria
that it should be greater than
10th feb because i do not want to count
10
feb it says after 10 february and then
you are saying the region
has to be east so we would want to find
out the total number of orders so
my region is east and that gives me the
result
now similarly you can also find out how
many times gill
sold pencils so here we will have to
give the range
so let's start with count
ifs now here i would want
that item is pencils so we can as well
select column 2
d 44
then you have to give your criteria so
that's your
pencil and then we are looking for sales
rep which is
kill so that is my column
c so let's say c 2
2 c 44
and the value should be just
kill
so it tells me it's twice
where gil has sold pencils so we can
obviously check this by going in here
choosing my filter and then
let's search for rep being just
gill okay
and now we are interested only in the
item being pencil
so i can say well let's get to pencil
only
and that tells me twice so you can
obviously re-verify using
filters but using functions or using
formulas
it is always good to calculate and
that can be making your computation and
calculation
more dynamic let's look at one more
interesting feature of
excel and that's your conditional
formatting
now as you see on the screen conditional
formatting
has different rules which can be applied
on your data
and that allows you to basically
differentiate
or easily identify data values
which are based on
certain criterias or rules so when you
talk about conditional formatting you
have different options
such as you can highlight cell rules you
can get
top and bottom values you can
apply different rules apply different
color scales and you
you can easily manage these rules
so conditional formatting is very useful
for people who would want to work on
huge amount of data and easily perform
some data analysis
it's easy to use as it is shown here
and with your conditional formatting you
can format cells based on a preset
condition
you can perform conditional formatting
to identify cells you can
highlight a few significant cells and
you can easily perform
conditional formatting as shown
on the left side now how do we work with
conditional formatting
let's have a quick look so say for
example we have
our excel sheet and if you see here i am
highlighting
the sales person who have generated
revenue greater than 10
000. so we can be looking at
the values where the revenue generated
by
a particular sales person is greater
than 10 000
it has a particular color
and how do we get here so for example
let's select this data
and what i could do is i could
go into conditional formatting now i
could basically highlight cell rules
and we could just say greater than
that's an easier way
i could also go ahead and create a new
rule
but then i can use one of this option i
can say greater than
and let's give some value might be we
would be
interested in looking at any value
greater than twelve
thousand so let's choose twelve
thousand
and here it says what color would you
want to select
so for example i would say
something like
yellow filled with dark yellow text
and let's say okay so right now what i'm
doing is
i have all the values where the revenue
generator was greater than 10 000
but then i have also selected all the
sales
people who have made or who have
generated revenue
greater than 12 000. so i can just wait
ctrl
z to see the previous result now here
i had the values which were greater than
10 000
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than twelve thousand
so this is one simple example now we can
look at some other examples
say for example you want to format cells
using three color scale
so if you look at the values here i have
a three color scale
mainly in green yellow and red
and how do you do this so for example i
can go in here
and i can go to conditional formatting
so i would want to
go for color scales and here you can
create different rules
so we can set up a two color scale
so we can say format only values that
are
above and below average i can format
only cells that contain
something i can get the top and bottom
values so these are different ways in
which
i can have a three color
based scale now what i will do is i will
select this
and let me show you the rule which i
have so for example
i can go into manage rules and if you
see here there are
certain rules which have been specified
now what does that mean
so you would want to specify a three
grade
scale so for example if i would want to
look at my first rule
it tells me that i'm choosing three
color scale i can choose lowest value
percentile and highest value and that
basically will
select the cells based on their values
so what we could have done is i can
basically
use one of these values i can delete
these rules which i have created
so for example i have all these
rules but you should always carefully
remember
that the rules will be applied in the
order shown
so for example if i just delete these
rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back now
it does not have any highlighting now i
can go in here
i can say condition sorry conditional
formatting
i could go for color scales or i could
basically
go into new rule
so i would want the
cells to be using three color scale so
let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale
it says what will be the color of lowest
value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red
i can say midpoint is percentile 50
and then the highest value is green and
if that looks good let's say okay
and now if you see the lowest values
have been highlighted as
red you have mid values
and then you have the positive value so
this is a three color scale and that
easily helps me in identifying the data
based on the cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do
is you can basically color the cells
based on their value so what we are
seeing here
is if the revenue generated
is greater than average then that
shows in green and if the revenue
generated
is lesser than average that's shows
in orange now how do we do that so we
can
basically again manage some rules so i
can basically create a new rule
now here i can select one of the options
which says format only values that are
above or below average and that's the
option i would want to select
now i can select this and it says format
values that are
above average so in our case we had it
in green
so for example i'll say above average
and then here i can go for
a particular color so you can go for a
particular size
so let's go and look into
the formatting so for example let's
choose yellow say okay
now i'm saying wherever the
cell values are above average it would
be
yellow instead of green and
let's go in here let's go and look into
manage rules
so this is basically the rule which we
are applying now we can also
add a new rule and
i need to select the values so for
example
i will say
here so we had gone for above now we'll
go for
below we'll go for format we will choose
red we'll say okay we'll say
now these are basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to
your data so right now it has not been
applied
so for example if i select this and then
i could basically choose my area
just hit on enter and similarly you can
go in here
and then select your area
hit on enter and say apply say
okay and now if you see i have really
chosen bright colors but then
i have said wherever my revenue
generated is above
average it should be in yellow and
below average should be in red so we
wanted
above average to be in green
and below average to be in orange so
that's what we have here right so you
can always
color code your cell values based on
some rules which you are setting up
now similarly you can also
find the top 10 and bottom 10 values
and that's pretty easy so you can just
select
this and then you can go into
conditional formatting you can go for
top and bottom values
top 10 items bottom 10 items
or you can go in for more rules so you
can say
format only top or bottom ranked values
so you have top 10 now you can choose
the color and for example i'll go
for blue
and i'll say okay so now if you see
my top 10 values are blue now similarly
i can add one more rule
so i can say new rule and i can say
let's go for top or bottom let's go for
bottom let's go for format let's say
orange say okay say okay
and that's it so now you have your
values which are
top or bottom 10 values
so you are using conditional formatting
where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors
and here easy conditional formatting
based on different rules helps us to do
that now similarly
you can also have the values
which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing so what
we can do is we can select our
columns either you could apply this to
all the columns now here i have applied
this only to
jan and april now i could apply this for
june so let's say june so you can go for
gradient fill
you can go for solid fill you can
obviously just select
the color and that takes care of the
things
you can say for example select this and
now this is selected but i would want to
might be format this so i can go in here
i can go into manage rules now that will
tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so i can just do a edit
rule
and that basically says this is a solid
fill
which is color you have no border this
is basically color as black
now i can go for something like gradient
fill
and i can say okay and now if i say
apply
and okay so this basically is like your
first column
so you can use conditional formatting
for various use cases
and you can highlight the values so
anyone who would look at the value would
automatically
notice which are the higher values which
are lower values might be
here the revenue is getting generated
or was getting generated but did not
grow beyond a particular value
and so on now similarly you can
also go in for different options
say for example here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased or say for
example if the revenue was going up
for this particular sales person so here
we are looking at carol
so in jan the revenue generation by
sales was very high
then in feb it was falling down
in march it was kind of stable
then in april it went way below so we
can
obviously work on this wherein we can
grade our cell values so what we can do
is we can go in for
highlighting the cell values now you can
go for color scales you can go for
icon sets and this is where you can
choose
your different shapes so you could
choose one of these shapes
so for example i would be interested in
looking at the indicators like
directional i could go using this three
arrows
i can go in for this color i can choose
directional
and then my values are
automatically using directional
now what we can also do is we can then
go into manage rules
and that basically tells me what rules
have been applied
so for example the latest one is the
icon set
which i have chosen it shows the
selected
columns i can obviously do a edit rule
and then
i can choose so i'm saying the format
style
is icon sets i'm not using a data bar
i'm not using color scale
now here i have chosen the style of
icons
and then here you can basically give
some values
so you have icon which is green when the
value
is greater than or equal to 67
percentage when i say
hyphen or minus it is less than 67
it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit
and easily highlight your cell values
based on this icon set so i can apply
this
and that's how i use conditional
formatting so conditional formatting can
be very useful
if you would want to use icon set
if you want to use your data bars if you
would want to
highlight particular values if you would
want to color code based on
some calculation if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to
just find out values based on some
simple
calculation so conditional formatting is
used extensively by data analysts
or people who are working business
intelligence teams or people who would
want to use
excel to easily identify the data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value
or finding out less significant or more
significant cells
to then pull out values and carry out
your computations calculations or
analysis so let's continue learning on
using excel for various things now we
have learnt on conditional formatting
and seen how that can be very helpful
let's learn one more feature of excel
and that's basically your data
validation
now this can be very useful when you
would want to work
on validating the data which is being
fed in the cells so you could limit it
to
basically a number between a particular
value
you could also add some messages to it
if you would want or you could even
circle invalid data or clear validation
circles
so data validation really helps us in
validating the data which is being
fed in to particular fields
now it's a feature in excel which is
mainly used to control what a user can
fill in a cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered
you can also restrict user to enter only
valid data
and if any invalid data is entered an
error message will be
displayed now that's where you can use
your data validations
so let's see how that can be done so for
data validation let's
see some exercises here so for example
you have
a name column and you would want to
restrict
that the name should accept only 15
characters now how do you do that
so you can basically select the cells
or you can just select a particular cell
and then we can later drag the property
to other fields
now here once the cell is selected so
for example let's
try this out and let's see if that works
so for example i will say peter
johnson okay and that
is basically 5 and 9
and 12 characters so let's say
junior and if i do this
it says input length is greater than 15
do you want to continue
if i say yes right so basically
it is allowing me to add the value here
but then
it has basically violated the
rule now this is giving a message to the
user
that the user name should be entered
less than 15 characters now how do we do
that
so for this we can basically select the
column
and then we can search for data tab and
get into data validation
so this is where you can create or
select different kind of rules
so for example i can go into data
validation
i can go into settings and i can say the
text length
and that should be less than 15
now this is the maximum i'm giving and
it says apply these changes to all other
cells within the same
settings so i can do this or i can just
drag and drop so i can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact
randomly check in any particular cell is
the rule applied
so it says text length less than 15. so
we can basically
control data validation in this
particular column
and that will allow only 15 characters
it will pop up a message if the user
really wants to go beyond the
particular limit now you also have
similarly date of birth
so the restriction is date of birth
should be between 10 jan 1990
to 30 december 1998.
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that
so we can select the field we can click
on data validation and if you see here
i have selected date and then date is
between
and then obviously you can give a range
that is 10 jan date 1990
12 30 1998 so that's the start and the
end
filter which has been applied and once
this is done
you can also check your input messages
which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid
date so if you see here on the left
there is a pop-up which is coming up
which says enter a valid date
now i can also say when user enters
invalid data show this error alert so i
can say stop
i can say invalid entered
and this is how i have set a rule so for
example if i just do
something like this and that says
invalidate
entered i can do a retry it will take me
back here but
unless and until i did not
give the right format the date will not
be accepted
and again the same thing applies to all
the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have
at the rate present in the value
provided now for this
we can use a formula and we can select
well i would want to apply this rule to
all these rows starting from c2
to c14 so let's get into data validation
let's look in settings and here we
are choosing custom now within custom
i am choosing what is the formula
so i am saying is number
and then i am saying find at the rate
for the rows c2 to c14
so the only thing we are concerned about
here
is the value should have an email
icon you can input a particular message
you can say what has to be done for
error alert so for example we can
basically go in here and we can say
invalid email
that's the title i'm giving and we can
say
email should contain
at the rate so if i do this and if i say
okay
now you can test it so you can say abcd
and that says email should contain at
the rate
and basically that will not allow me to
add the values
so now you have the field called salary
it says salary should be greater than 50
000.
now we can limit the values by choosing
a whole number so for example for salary
i can go into data validation i can go
into settings
so here i can say something like
decimal or i can go for whole number
so both of the things are fine it
depends on what kind of values get into
this particular field
so if i say whole number and if i say it
has to be greater than 50
000 so i'm saying the minimum is
50 000 or i could have given a decimal
and then i can say greater than less
than
equal or anything or even between
so i can select greater than and then i
can just say
okay now for rank the rule is
rank should be between 100 and 200
so again we can use a whole number so
ranks will
generally not be decimal so this would
be whole number
salary is can be a whole number
or it could be decimals so we have
chosen decimal here
and in rank if you click on data
validation
i have chosen whole number
i have set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends
i can give this so this is how you can
just do a simple data validation
and control the values which land in the
cell okay
so now let's also understand how we can
restrict the values in a particular cell
which might be based on a list of items
now for example here if you see i have
two columns
so one column basically has the values
of city
names and then you have places within
that particular city
so if i would want to implement a data
validation
based on this so for example if you see
here city
and that basically shows me only the
four values which can be entered
and if i go to place then it tells me
for
maharashtra i can only enter pune mumbai
now how do i do this so say for example
you take an empty field and you want to
restrict the values of city names
so i could select data validation i
could basically select
list and then it tells me you need to
enter the list values that is the source
so you click here and then i can just
select these fields
now if i do this and if i say ok
it has implemented a data validation but
if you look into
this it will show me the same thing but
then
it shows me some empty cells which
did not have any value so this is fine
but it would be better if we do it
in a different way so i can select this
and i have already given my city names
here
so i can just do a data validation and
here in the source let me get rid of
this
now i can just have my cursor here
i can select these values and then if i
say okay
so now if you see my city names have
been restricted to
these values and that's how you can
implement
your data validation so i have
this data validation here but i will get
rid of this one
by just doing a control z now i'll come
here
and say for example i would want to
implement the same data validation
now the easiest way would be in doing
this
for all my four cities now if you see
here
i have data validation i could choose
bangalore
and if you come and check here there is
no data validation but we have
implemented data validation here now how
is that done
so i could select this or for example i
can go in here
i can select data validation i can
select
list and then here in the source
i will say for bangalore the value
should be
these and then if i basically say
ok now if we see
these are the values which are fed into
bangalore
so we could do this or like what we have
done
here so if you can check the data
validation rule
i have used list and then i have said
indirect f2 so basically
i am giving in a formula which relates
to
the value which is in for the city
maharashtra so we could do this or in a
simpler way
we could do this and then just drag and
drop here
so we could check for maharashtra what
are the values
let's choose a different city so for
example kolkata
and here i will choose now since we did
a drag and drop
it has basically taken the values of
bank load so that's not right
so we select this we go into data
validation
and here i can either
feed in the values that is such as
bangalore
i could basically say something like
this
kolkata and i could say okay
so now if you see it shows me the places
in kolkata
now here we have let's choose a
different city so for example let's go
for delhi
and here i can go to data validation
and i can just say delhi so
this is an easier way of doing it or
if you remember the formula then what
you can do is
you can just give in indirect
and then basically give the
value of the cell for which you would
want to
keep in the values so this is how you
can do list validation
so you can provide a list of values and
then you can restrict
the values in a cell which should be
belonging to a particular list so this
is how you do a
simple data validation by restricting
the
data in the form of a list
now let's learn about pivot charts and
tables which is
one more very useful feature of excel
and which allows you to
work with your data or perform data
analysis
now pivot table is a summary of your
data
it is used in cases where there are
numerous rows and columns in your data
set
and it allows you to group your data in
several ways so that you can derive
meaningful information from it
now the visual representation of a pivot
table is termed as
a pivot chart now how do we do that so
let's see an example
now here is some data here you see we
have some row labels
which basically gives me some category
of
items here it also tells me the sum of
sales
and basically it gives me per item
what is the total sum of sales which
were made now how do i get this
here so for example if i would want to
delete this and i would be interested in
getting the
total sales under each category of items
now we know that we have different data
here
and it's huge for example on the
row end if i just do a control and right
arrow it tells me what's my right
last column and if i just do a control
and down arrow it tells me there are
9994 rows
now i can use this and what i can do is
i can basically work on
insert and go to pivot table now this
basically tells you need to choose the
range now since
i have chosen my first row and first
column
it basically has selected the data and
that's fine
now do you want the result in a new
worksheet i'll say
existing worksheet and i can choose a
location now that basically needs me to
select a field
might be we can just select this field
and that
should be good enough so for example if
i close this
or if i say okay so
this is basically an indication that my
pivot table
will be created now what are the fields
we are interested in
so as per the problem we need to find
out what the total sales for each
category so let's go in here and let's
select the field
category now as soon as you do that it
shows that
the rows which are
being selected are for this column
category
and now we are interested in getting the
sales
so we would want the sales per category
so let's select this
so you see sum of sales is selected now
close this
and that's it that's that's your data so
it shows you row labels
it tells you what are the different
categories
and it also gives you sum of sales
which is per category now this is
one easy example where we have solved
the problem where we have tried to find
what were the total sales under each
category
of items so for example let's have
another data set so again you can just
check how many rows we have
and it is basically the same 9994
and if i look in columns it basically
shows me profit is the last column
and here we would want to find out
which category so for example let me get
rid this
with sub category of items sold the
maximum under
each category so we have some categories
here
which says furniture and it shows some
sub categories
and then it shows me office supplies and
then some sub categories and same thing
with technology now we know how we
got this data but this is different than
what we were seeing here
so here we were just getting the
categories but but we did not have any
breakdown
of sub categories within this particular
category
and here you see there is a breakdown
and then basically you can also
apply a filter which basically says
what is the data you want and if you are
interested in
finding out a particular value now how
do we do this
so for example let me get rid of this
now we know how we can find out the
category of items
but we would want to find out which sub
category of items sold the maximum
under each category so here we are not
looking at sales but we are looking at
the quantity
okay so what we can do is we can go to
the first row and first column click on
insert
click on pivot table data is already
selected
let's choose existing worksheet let's
choose a location in our worksheet where
we would want
to have this so might be i can select
this particular field
and then just close this so it says this
is the existing worksheet say okay
and now you need to select your columns
so for example if
i would want the data for categories so
i can select this now i know
that within category these are the
options which we have and then there is
a sub category
so let's select that and if you see here
now we have the data which will be
filtered
so based on your category and sub
category
and then we will choose quantity so it
automatically understands that this is
something on which
summation can be done so let's select
this
and close on this now if you see here
we have got our items where
we can see the sub categories
within a particular category now i can
basically close this and that just shows
me
high level categories here so here
i can again select a particular
row and column i can go for
either a new pivot table so we could
basically select this the row is already
selected
existing worksheet is what i want so
now i will select this particular
place say okay now we do the same thing
like what we did earlier
so we will select category subcategory
and quantity so the data is already
coming
just select this and now you already
have
all your data but this is not what we
want we want to
basically apply a filter to this now how
do we do that
so we can go for slicer
so i can go for insert slicer and then
it tells
what are the sub categories which you
are interested
in so for example if i go for
something like sub category and say okay
so this tells me what are the categories
you are interested
in so for example we know that furniture
has furnishings with the highest value
so i can select say furnishings
and then i was interested in office
supplies
so within office supply i can basically
search for here
binder so i can just do a control and
select binder
and then i can also know for technology
i can select
phones so i will say control and select
phones
and now if you see the filter has been
applied
and we have these sub categories which
are selected
so we have our data here now we don't
need really this so i can just delete
this
and i have my data which shows me
furniture being the main category and
that has only furnishings
office supply having binders and
technology having phones and that
basically
is a filter applied on the result of
your pivot so this is how we are seeing
which subcategory of items were sold
maximum for each category
so this is how you can easily use pivot
tables and you can do some analysis let
us look at some more
examples now
let's see if you have to answer this
question which says
which were the top three states for each
region that made the highest average
profit
now how do we calculate that so for
example this is the data we have
and as i have instructed earlier you can
select the first row and first column
you can click on insert go into pivot
table
and that basically selects all your data
we will choose the result should be in
this existing worksheet
so select this click here and then
basically
let's select this cell
and i will say okay so now my pivot
table will be here so we
are interested in finding out top three
states
within each region which have made the
highest
profit or which have made the highest
average profit
so for that first we will select
region so when we select region it shows
here region and within region you will
then select state
so within every region you have multiple
states so that's what we are selecting
and then we are interested in looking at
the profit so let's select profit
and that automatically shows up here so
we can
now say close this so basically we have
all the data but we are looking at the
sum of profit but that's not what we
want
we are looking for top three states
from each region that made the highest
average profit now how do we change that
so
here we have sum of profit so i can do a
right click
and basically i can say summarize values
by
average so now i'm getting the average
here
and that basically tells per region
i have the average profit but first is
let's sort this data
so let's go into sort more options and
here
i have average of profit
or for example as i said you can select
region
say okay and now it is basically having
the
regions and then you have your
state value so again we can do a sorting
here
and i can say let's go for more sort
options
i'll say descending the state values
should be
based on average profit so let's say
okay
and now if you see in particular region
we have the data which has been
sorted wherein you have the highest
average profit on the top
now what we can also do is we can
basically
then go for filtering we can say top 10
but i'm not interested in top 10
so i could reduce this to top three
and this is the items average of profit
say okay
and now you see per region you have
the data which is showing me
top three states what are the average
and then
you are also looking at the subtotal so
which
basically says average profit for your
west
now if you would want to arrange this
your
west and south and east and central
in a particular alphabetical order if
you would want to sort it
you can always do a sorting and you can
choose sort z
to a if that's what you would want to do
or you can go for sorting
more sort options and you want to
sort the region which is as of now
based on descending z2a let's make it
ascending
say okay and now you see the data has
been filtered
so it says per region now
you can always select this and you can
say what is this
so this is basically your average of
profit
now we are looking at
each region and the states the top three
states as we wanted
within the region and what is the
average
now we have one more question what is
the percentage contribution of
each sub-category of products
under each category to the total sales
so we know there are different products
there are different categories
and all the categories contribute to the
total sales
so we would want to find out what is the
percentage contribution of each
sub category of products
under each category so we not only want
the
category percentage but we would also
want what is the contribution of each
subcategory
to each category to the total sales how
do we do that
so for that we need to again
just place our cursor here or select the
first row and first
column click on your insert click on
your pivot table
and now the data is already selected
existing worksheet
place your cursor here and then let's
select this
cell say okay now your pivot table
fields are here so we
are interested in category so let's
select
category and then within a category we
will have sub categories and we are
interested in the sales
data wherein it is already going to give
us the sum of
sales but we would want this in the form
of
percentage rather than just the sum
now we can click here value field
settings
and it says if you would want to
summarize this it says show
value as and what
are the values you would want so you can
straight away go ahead
here and say percentage of grand total
so we could do that because we know we
will get
a sum of sales and grand total now i
could basically say
in the percentage of grand total say
okay
and then just close this so once
you have closed this you see already
the data is in percentage
so now we have our data with
subcategories but we
also want the data to be sorted might be
in a descending order which tells
which subcategory is contributing more
than others
we can select how many sub categories we
are interested in
so we can basically select one of the
sub category cells
right click now you have option filter
and you have sorting so we can say more
sort
options now here i will say descending
and you want the descending to be
sum of sales which is already showing as
percentage
click on ok and now you see for each
category
it shows the percentage contribution
towards the sales
it shows the sub categories contribution
to a particular category and also to
total
sales so technically speaking if you
look at all these values which are
sub categories and if you would total
them that would be your total grand
total
so this is how we can solve a simple
problem like this
what is the percentage contribution of
each subcategory of products
under each category to the total
sales the next question is which
customer made the lowest profit
in the home office segment in each state
now here we know
that we are looking for home office
segment
we are looking for customer which made
the lowest profit
we are also looking for the state
as the main criteria so in each state
we would look for home office segment
and within that we would look for
customer which has made the lowest
profit that means
the lowest value of the profit
so how do we do this so let's say let's
get into
selecting our row and column we will go
into insert
i'll say pivot table i'll say existing
worksheet
and let me get my result
here so let's say okay now that gives me
the pivot table so the first thing
is we are looking at per state
and i would be interested in
[Music]
home office segment or i could first
start with segment
now here we have segment and in segment
i can basically select home office so i
can just do a uncheck and select home
office only
and now i can select
state so that will be my
sub category within segment and then
within
state we would want to find out the
customer so let's get the customer name
and we are interested in finding out the
lowest profit so let's select profit
and here we have sum of profits so the
fields are selected
close this and now you have your data
which basically shows me the names of
customers which made the
profit but it's it's not sorted so we
can sort this
and we have state entries also so that's
fine
so what i can do is here i can basically
say sorting go to more sort options
i can say i want to do a descending or i
want to do an
ascending and ascending based on
sum of profit so let's do that now you
see
the topmost value is the lowest value
per
state within home office segment
now what we also want is we just want
one value
per state so how do we do that so we can
just
go for filtering go for top 10 values
i'm interested in bottom value and in
that
also i'm looking for only the
lowest value so let's select one
say okay and now you see we have data
for home office segment
per state customer who has made the
lowest profit so we have easily answered
this question
using our pivot table now say for
example we have a question which says
find the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions
so the data has to be divided quarterly
and use order year as a slicer
we can do that by selecting what data we
would want to slice
and then we would want to create a pivot
chart
also so for example how do we do that so
for example
i will get rid of this i will get rid of
this my pivot chart which we can
recreate
so find the sales made in each quarter
of 2016 for all the regions
so this is what we want now how do we do
this
so for example let's select this
we will do a insert pivot table we will
basically say
existing worksheet and then i can select
this particular cell
i'll say okay and now i'm interested in
data quarterly so first let's select
our field here so we should basically
have
if all our fields are selected say for
example if i say
order date now
you see we have quarters and years
which are selected now we could be
selecting these fields which says
quarters years and if i would want
data to be filtered based on years i
could do that or i could get rid of here
so i have quarters
i have order date so
that's being already selected now what
else we need
we need to find out
for every region so let's select the
region
and we can also add region as a column
here
so that will basically give me all the
regions
as different columns and then finally we
want the sales so let's select this
and now let's look what we have
so if you see here we have our data
which is for each quarter
it gives me the total data but what we
would be interested in
is not looking at the total data but we
are only interested in
quarter of 2016. now how do we do that
so what we do here is we have row labels
so let's click on this
so we have date filters and then in date
filters we can go for between
and then we will say 2016
and the value has to be 1
and then let's select this
and let's change this to 2016
and this is 12th month
and then we can say 31.
so we are saying the date has to be 2016
and it basically says not a valid date
so let's select let's select a
particular date and see
so the month has to be here so let's see
in this
and let's make it date and say okay and
now we have our data which is
for 2016.
so for example i could basically select
this
and here i could be looking at
what are the filters we have so it says
clear filter from
order data so we have applied the filter
on
order date and
these are your date filters which is
basically
date 16 oh this is wrong
so this one has to be changed to 2016.
so select this and now we have our data
for 2016.
so we have found the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions the
grand total
for a particular quarter if we are
looking at the value
or for individual months in a particular
quarter
and we have sliced the data now we could
have also
introduced a slicer by
selecting which field we would want to
implement so for example if i would
select a particular field and then i
could click on slicer
i could choose i would want to slice the
date based on order date and then
could have done it or we have just given
the
date for 2016. now we just need to
plot a graph for this and that's very
easy so you just need to
select the complete pivot data
and here you have the chart options so
let's go for
line chart and that basically shows me
the line chart so we can select this
we can just drag and drop it here and
then
we can basically check if that is
showing us
the data so if you see here this is line
chart where it has divided the regions
in different colors
so we have all the regions we could
filter out in pivot chart a particular
region
we have the quarterly
time here in order data the filter is
applied
it says it is 2016. in quarters it tells
me
it is 16. so we have our data we have
created a pivot chart
and basically we have sliced the data
for
2016. let's answer
one more question and that's finding the
profit made in
each year for all the categories
of products in east and west regions
only and then we would want to create a
histogram
for the same pivot table so histogram
usually gives us the
frequencies so let's look at how do we
calculate the
profit made in each year for all the
categories
so what i can do is i can basically
select my row id here and now i'll do a
pivot table
so the data is already selected i'll
choose existing worksheet let's select
this particular cell
say okay now what are we interested in
now if you look at the fields we don't
see any
years or quarters and so on so for
example here i can just choose
order date and then basically
i can choose say for example
years or quarters the data which is
coming out from my order date so
here i will just select years
now then i have my
order date so we are interested in
the years orders and
we are interested in let's look at our
column or the question what we had here
so we have years find the profit made in
each year so let's select profit
so that basically says sum of profit but
then
i'm also interested in
for all the categories of products
so what i can do is here i have
my field which is category and that i'll
add to the columns
so that shows me what are the different
categories
and this looks fine now i'm also
interested in east and west regions
so that is basically in the region so
either we could add a slicer or we could
do a filtering here
by adding the filters so first is i'll
click on
region and here it says select all i'm
only interested in east and west so
let's select this
take this put it here
let's say okay and now we have the data
which has been filtered
based on the region so here we have
region
so you can always look at the filter it
is east and west
and we have our year data
per year we have different categories
you can always look at what are these
column labels so this is
my different categories and this is the
profit
per category and then you have your
grand total
so we have already our data now let's
say
close this so we have our data for
all these years different categories the
profits made per year
and if i would want i could go into an
year
and i could look into different months
so that also
is showing up and now we would want to
basically plot a histogram with this
data
so i can just place my cursor here
i can select this and then i can go into
insert and here i have different options
so we can go for
bar chart we can go for insert hierarchy
chart
we can go into waterfall funnel stock
surface or radar chart so there are
different options what you have here
and we will go for a simple histogram
which is two dimensional
let's select this and here you see you
can
obviously select different regions
you have your years which shows up
you have your order date and then you
have your categories which can be chosen
for your histogram
or for your bar chart and that basically
is how
you use your pivot table you use some
calculations and then you can plot
your needed graph to visualize the data
and understand it in a better way
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here